c'mere Dom Brava is editor-in-chief of
Polish radio broadcasting and a
committed journalist under his
instruction the European and the Polish
anthems were played on the hour every
hour as a warning
compose keys the Polish anthem is the
most important piece of music for every
poll and the ode to joy' for every
European with that we're trying to draw
attention to what's happening in state
media at the moment on Friday Dom Bravo
was fired the Polish government is
systematically replacing the heads of
public radio and television the marathas
colleague still has his job journalists
are primarily afraid that their
contracts will be terminated at least
that's what the government announced it
would do under its new media reform
supposedly all contracts will be
annulled and only after they've been
reviewed will some journalists be
re-employed an atmosphere of fear an
outrage is currently driving thousands
onto the streets and protest those
responsible for the reform at the Polish
culture ministry are apparently
surprised by the uproar no of course I
didn't expect the criticism to be that
massive even though I welcome all this
excitement across the board about the
public media I just wish it had come
sooner that's criticism directed at the
previous government it also
instrumentalized the media and put its
own people in charge that has been a
thorn in the side of Polish journalists
for years there's no solidarity among
polish journalists the media is deeply
divided many journalists are extremely
politicized and even in the public media
you'll hear people saying I'm left or
right leaning and that's why the
government has conceived the new reform
which it believes will lead to a
so-called healthy turnaround to the
culture ministry that means a strong
national and independent media with
management loyal to the party
time will tell whether we
instrumentalize the media our
predecessors definitely did it didn't
matter whether the positions were open
to everyone they always took the
candidates from the ruling parties open
positions aren't even made public
anymore meanwhile come Adam Brava has
been replaced with someone true to the
party
under those conditions comer says he
cannot and will not work as a journalist
for state radio